there you are
overwatch is an exercise and refined
chaos there are multitudes of layers
hiding beneath the hectic surface and
they emerge one after another the more
you play this is a shooter that knows
how to surprise one that unfolds at a
frantic pace one that takes a handful of
great ideas and combines them into
something spectacular at first glance
it's a simple formula two teams of six
vie for control of mobile payloads
capture points and key strategic
positions each of these four modes are
easy to grasp serving is the foundation
of the various maps and powerful heroes
colliding within them that apparent
simplicity is deceiving though overwatch
is an amorphous shape-shifting organism
that can be different things for
different players depending on which
hero you choose and what role you assume
within the context of your team the
quality of overwatch as a hero shooter
relies on its fighters and these 21
characters both in terms of personality
and design compose one of the more
distinct and diverse casts in recent
memory their dialogue hints at
relationships among the group their art
design conveys a colorful visual
vocabulary their ability set the stage
for multi-dimensional firefights with
explosions energy shields and bursts of
sonic energy there's an enticing balance
between mastering one character and
trying someone completely new each of
these characters could be the center of
their own game overwatch also functions
as a sort of time machine borrowing
elements from the shooter genre
throughout its evolution over the years
some of overwatch is characters display
the arena combat of quake while others
capture the dynamism of the more modern
titanfall
over watch also even includes arc types
to introduce military shooter fans into
a more nuanced overall experience
these heroes may be the bricks
comprising overwatch a structure but the
map design is the mortar in between
these maps mix high walkways and low
pits narrow sight lines with wide
avenues battles change constantly choke
points become virtual morgues and
learning to use your character's ranged
damage movement speed and special
abilities is contingent on what the
environments dictate what's impressive
isn't overwatch is ambition its attempt
to bring all these different factors
together under one roof what's
impressive is that it fits its
characters and interactions into one
organic being with ever-changing
scenarios that keep overwatch fresh as
each match begins but even more vital is
the ease with which overwatch teaches
you valuable lessons in these moments
overwatch is telling you one important
thing there is no single way to play
however unlike the post match voting
period the highlight video places most
of its emphasis on killstreaks these are
flashy but they don't recognize healers
or tank characters that often it's a
minor complaint and only stands out
because the rest of overwatch is so
accommodating to individual play styles
but it's jarring nonetheless it's also
disappointing how overwatch stumbles
with its randomized loot system these
awards are all aesthetic to be clear but
too often loot crates contain unwanted
items they delay the process of
outfitting your favorite characters the
ones you use most often the ones you
grow attached to in this respect
overwatch uses gambling to undermine
your desire for specific unlocks but in
almost every other way
overwatch encourages a more tangible
sort of progression that of filling a
critical role on your team and
understanding its intricacies the more
you play adapt and grow there is a
genuine learning process here there is
real value to the time you dedicate to
understanding these overlapping systems
and it's that intoxicating path of
discovery that makes overwatch so very
so rewarding and ultimately another
seminal release from developer Blizzard
overwatch is an intelligent cascade of
disparate ideas supporting one another
pouring into one another and coiling
around themselves as they flow into the
brilliant shooter underneath
you
you